Petit:
I'm sure he'll go all the way from Otaru to the north just to tell
you that.  It's my
job to buy my granddaughter
safely.I wonder if
you're the man who killed three of your comrades-in-arms in the Tsurumi Chuyo Shinpo newspaper
.  It's the brown bear that killed it, so
there's no doubt about it because I was there.
Even if
I don't believe it, the fate is because of the Ainu's old way of thinking,
and I had a dream a long time ago, and it was
a dream in which
many bears gathered around my daughter and
sent it to me.
Soon after that, my mother died of an illness,
so I believe in dream fortune-telling.
There's
something
I really want to
know.Know what you need to know and move forward for your own future.
[music]
woooooo